what are your thoughts on when an
artist's work stops being about the work
and it's now
about the artist i mean because now
people it seems like when you get to the
level of a quentin tarantino
link later whomever it's no longer like
wow there's a great film it's oh it's
their film
so now you're going to judge it through
the previous films or any news or
whatever
and now they're under a new set of
criteria that no longer has to do with
the story
that's interesting i think
some
i think some people directors might
be skewed that way and i guess it
depends on which angle you're coming
from like
do you see their stamp because you know
it's their movie because they have
a certain style what have you that's who
they are
right so you're gonna see that the other
side i guess would be placating into
that
um right is that kind of where you're
asking like when does it be when do they
shift or when do we shift as an audience
that's a good question actually
that's a good question to my question
because i was thinking it's more
about the the they're up against critics
they're up against people that love
their work
and they're up against attractors which
is going to definitely come at that
level
whether it's valid or not you know
especially in the film world
there's a lot of people that are vying
for these certain spots and because
there's so few of them
it lends itself to a lot of like trying
to take people down
you know a couple notches you know i i
could speak to it this way i think
um i think as a filmmaker you have to
consider your audience
right and there's
and then there's a responsibility in
that like what do they
expect and where does that meet
your art right
and i'm sure that's a very difficult
balance
for for directors or or anybody
at that level i i think quentin very
much
respects his audience and loves his
audience he's a fan
himself so if he's watching
um a bruce lee film
i suspect that he wants to see certain
things from him
right because of his love for him
so i i would hope that
they relish in that without
succumbing to their own press right
sure and the audience you know we have a
we've got a tough crowd with the
audience they could be rather fickle
yeah and they can have their own reasons
for being fickle you know
we've seen different directors that have
had one hit after another
and then unfortunately something doesn't
take and then
it's just like a feeding frenzy and it's
not warranted in my opinion but
and then there's the the whole thing of
movie critics and
are those critics actually filmmakers or
are they
connoisseurs of cinema but they've never
actually done it
right and so who's you know anyway
that's another conversation but i was
just curious because at that level
it's so much i mean he's become you know
just the same as kevin smith or whoever
it's it's about oh well this is a kevin
smith film or the sequence
it's not like the people don't see it
with eyes of just this is just a film
wow i really like the story i've heard
that about uh once upon a time in
hollywood
a little bit because he really just goes
and
after doing this documentary and
watching that
like i'll go back to why i wanted to do
the documentary to begin with like
watching people do what they're really
good at what they love
is amazing and i see that all over that
film he loves los
angeles and you see the love for los
angeles in the film
right you know he loves the what if
scenario
you definitely see that you know um
so it's a great film and it stands on
its
own without having a tarantino knowledge
before right so beautiful film um
i think that's why he also says i'm only
doing 10.
i think he's cutting off again because i
think he's brilliant with regard to all
aspects of filmmaking including this
he doesn't want to be the old man
director he doesn't want to be uh i
think eli roth digs into this a little
bit
you know he's a and tim roth actually uh
they like he's only doing 10. he wants
to stay fresh he wants to say you know
and
maybe that's maybe that's part of the
reason maybe
like he doesn't want to be judged that
at that point
or he doesn't want to make those
mistakes
i don't know it's interesting to think
about though
right but he's definitely stopping he's
definitely you know he's
and how fascinating is that and this
isn't like one of these farewell tours
where like someone says yeah
this is the last one he doesn't seem
like the kind of guy that to mince words
you know he's
very he he kind of sticks to his his
he has his idea of something and he
executes it and
that's how he feels i i don't think he's
changed much
uh in that way you know he's
he's never apologized for oh you oh
was it too much violence for you did i
say the n word too much
did i hurt too many women did you know
there's no
he's like no it's a story that's where
it lives and he owns it
sure well it's like howard stern show if
you're going to tune in
you know what you're going to get you
know and it's it's it's not for children
and and
you're going to laugh at times and maybe
you'll be offended others but
you know what you're getting and so
don't watch it don't
listen if you don't want that i don't
know that's just my opinion and
yeah but uh but definitely love to go in
there and judge it though
well a quote i think from howard and i
think this is something that you
told me david was that that his haters
watched his show
more often or listened to it than the
people oh just to sit there and be
offended right i just want to sit here
and be offended over and over again so i
have something to complain about
i've said this about east coasters
because i'm from there so don't judge
um you know coming out to for in texas
for a while and coming out to
california oh like you know what do east
coasters like to do like what's like the
past time whatever
it's like complaining complaining like
they love it
they love it they love it well if the
weather's always cold yeah you got to
stay inside do something
which is ornery because of the snow
you